wie sitze ich eigentlich mache ich gar
die ganze den gesamten sind elefanten so
wenn man jedoch könnte das motto hallo
meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einem video über 20 gaming
fakten über mich ich habe sehr oft über
benötigt übersetzt amerikanisch richtig
weiß auch scheißegal jedenfalls habe ich
mir gedacht heute am sonntag manchmal
wieder ein konter solo wir live video wo
ich euch einfach mal 20 dinge sage die
ich beim zocken tue
eigenschaften die ich habe bestimmte
steuerungselemente was mein
lieblingsspiel ist das eine lieblings
konsole ist ein paar hintergründe bleibt
einfach 20 fakten über mich beim zocken
über das zocken mit mir in verbindung et
cetera ich würde sagen von diagrammen
mit der ersten sache und zwar weil mein
erster hand hält beziehungsweise das
erste produkt womit ich spielen konnte
weil ich hatte damals noch kein handy
wir waren nicht damals elfjährige kinder
die schon mit mai von einer schülerin
gelaufen sind
ich hatte nämlich damals ein gameboy
radfahrens das war doch dieses längliche
teil
das ist so ein bisschen aus wie dieser
new dickes controller ding nur halt ohne
licht und alles meine mutter hat mir da
experten nicht noch dran gebaut und
alles mögliche und das war auf jeden
fall mein erster meine erste konsole mit
der habe ich richtig lang gezockt also
wirklich immer so weiß nicht ich glaub
ich hatte die echt zwei jahre lang nur
dieses ding hat damit täglich gezeigt
also das war für meine erste konsole um
zweite sache ist ich liebe simple
pixelige einfach total einfache spiele
deswegen mache ich zum beispiel auch
minecraft und deswegen machte ich auch
flat bird so gern also habe ich dabei
ziemlich aufgeregt aber es war ein
richtig geiles spiel
zurzeit zocke ich auch am meisten discos
und auch so etwas wie timber man also
auf dem iphone sind jetzt als iphone
spielt sich gerade aufgezählt habe so
richtig simple spiele mag ich einfach
weil ich finde es kommt nicht auf die
grafik an ich muss als nächstes auf dem
handy beispielsweise nämlich mal als
beispiel zocken wo ich die heftigste
grafik hab da gibt es ja dieses von epic
games infiniti oder irgendwie
oder sword keine ahnung wieso das
brauche ich nicht ich brauche einfach
als simples was ich so zwischendurch
spielen kann oder wie koloss auch ganz
cool also so simple einfache sachen mag
ich einst bei ballerspielen die
beispielsweise cod oder battlefield oder
anderen sachen ist es ja eigentlich so
dass man sich mit der tat mit der cs
taste produkt also man geht dann so
geduckt wenn man diese taste gedrückt
hat oder einmal drauf drückt ich stelle
bei jedem spiel das auf die alt-taste
werde ich habe auch eine ganz andere
hand position die ich drücke und neben
nämlich nicht dieses schiff wenn man
schneller laufen will dich nicht mit dem
kleinen finger sondern auch mit denen
wir mit dem ringfinger alles möglich ich
habe das ein bisschen umgestellt
also ich habe eine ganz eigene steuerung
bei ballerspielen und ja das ist anders
kann komme ich auch gar nicht mit klar
irgendwie mein absolutes lieblingsspiel
was ich hier auf meinem leben so am
nicht am längsten gespielter am längsten
habe ich auf jeden fall fifa gespielt
aber was ich am geilsten fand war
einfach gta 5 es kam sogar so weit dass
ich mir dass ich hatte eine freistunde
als das rausgekommen ist in zum
mediamarkt gefallen haben dass gekauft
nach hause gefahren
geht es jetzt auch gezockt und einfach
mal die nächsten drei schulstunden
verpennt ach so dass das jetzt waren und
sport und grinst auch nicht so schlimm
aber ich war wirklich so im spiel drin
und das war so geil und alles mögliche
diese ganzen elemente die man das was
man alles machen kann und gta 5 würde
ich sagen ist das spiel das bisher am
allerbesten vorne was die offenbar auch
mal eine sache bezüglich gta 5 und zwar
allgemein open world spielen immer wenn
ich ein open-world-spiel spiele gucke
ich mich zuerst komplett um das heißt
wenn mir der sagt okay fand der position
und unterhalte ich mich mit dem typen
der wird in auftrag geben oder dann
musst du dein auto klauen oder blogger
plan wenn er das sagt denk ich mir so
nah kommt wichtig der punkt ist zwar
dahin im norden ich war bei erstmal in
süden und guck mir da noch mal die ganze
welt an und alles mögliche und ich muss
erstmal quasi so nicht alles erkunden
aber so ein bisschen die welt erkunden
wie beispielsweise in assassin's creed
oder gta 5 oder red dead redemption da
gibt's ja ganz ganz viele spiele wo ich
das gemacht habe und dass auf jeden fall
heftig krasse angewohnheit von mir ich
muss immer erst alles erkunden ja ich
musste mehrere jahre darum kämpfen eine
ps3 zu bekommen ich war nämlich damals
irgendwie war es vielleicht die konsole
soll schon zehn jahren oder so ich war
12 und dann ich möchte meine ps3 und
plattler braucht erstmal fernseher habe
ich ein jahr darum gebettelt dass ich
fernsehe willkommen abgespart mir
fernseher gekauft das ist übrigens der
hinten
der ist auch schon relativ alt also
sieben acht jahre oder so und dann habe
ich darum gebettelt dass ich mir eine
playstation 3 kaufen darf dann musste
ich wieder ein jahr darum betteln und
dann hab ich die zwei wochen bekommen
dann war die freude natürlich groß war
mein erstes spiel an der big planet und
das habe ich auch so viel gezockt und
alles möglich wir waren richtig richtig
eine richtig lange durststrecke bis zu
meiner ersten konsolen ist es relativ
peinlich und zwar denken viele von euch
oder finden viele von euch
wahrscheinlich auch das gremium das
beste rollenspiel ist was es bisher je
gab und ja denn der intention auch das
spiel gekauft und wie ihr vielleicht
wisst hasse ich spinnen über alles ich
kann überhaupt nicht ab ich kann die gar
nicht ab wenn die auch noch über wir
sind jetzt über mir so eine spinne wer
dann
ich würd die krise kriegen das aber
keine jedenfalls habe ich skytrain
damals deinstalliert als in dieser
ersten anfangshöhe diese ganzen spinnen
aufgetauchter escape gedrückt alte vier
alles raus deinstalliert und es liegt
jetzt irgendwo bei mir im zimmer wo man
sich ob es jetzt gerade vielleicht zehn
minuten gespielt weil einfach sind
spinnen aufgetaucht und war ich kann
darauf gar nicht klar das ist richtig
richtig komisch bei mir ich habe mit 15
damals spieler ab 18 gespielt
das ist nicht erfolgt sondern immer wenn
ich dann wenn irgend elternteil reinkam
oder meiner oma oder irgendwie mal sowas
und eine tante habe ich immer schnell
den fernseher ausgemacht und alles
schnell ausgemacht und bin da
wahrscheinlich in dem spiel online
fünfmal gestorben oder so aber einfach
weil so nein die dürften nicht sehen ich
spiele ganz heftige sache die dann immer
so warum sitzt vor einem schwarzen
fernsehen ach ja die sendung war gerade
vorbei ich komme mit nach unten
nach dem motto soja guckt mal besser
nicht nach ausgespielt passt auch ganz
gut und was meine mutter viel tolerant
aber irgend welchen krieg spielen als
mein vater das war zum beispiel damals
krass als ich 14 war und mein erstes
spiel ab 16 bekommen ob das für
assassin's creed 2 glaube ich damals war
es so dass meine mutter meinte ach ja
kommt hat er einst geschrieben das sagt
schon haben und habe dann immer so dass
ab 16 man das im krieg schwer ich mag
das nicht meine mutter ist ja echt viel
toleranter ich war damals auf stufen
fahrt in italien und da hat ein kumpel
candy crash auf dem handy dann habe ich
das ganze zeit mit dem zusammen da
gezockt und ich habe da eine nacht lang
von candy crash geträumt weil ich davon
so süchtig war
haltet mich für verrückt ich habe
insgesamt sieben computermäuse die ich
über zwei jahre langen weg immer so
zugelegt habe weil ich nie so werde ich
dir eine maus hat dann nehme ich mir so
nahe kommen dies doch nicht sogar nur
damit sich kaputt gegangen mittlerweile
benutze ich seit fünf monaten glaube ich
die razer mamba und mit der bin ich
total zufrieden das ist keine
produktplatzierungen oder so aber
einfach nur eine empfehlung die razer
mamba finde ich ist bisher meine beste
maus hatte noch direkt korn und liga
total kacke und keine ahnung ich hatte
bisher sieben computermäuse über zwei
jahre verteilt ich habe ja einen imac
wie eventuell meiner mutter gesehen hat
und in meinem mein setup video und ich
hab da windows drauf und ich habe mir
damals nur windows drauf gepackt nicht
um youtube zu machen kann machen zu
können um fraps benutzen zu können etc
sondern einfach damit ich pc spiele
zocken konnte
ich habe mir einfach eine windows lizenz
gekauft und gut kann man alles
eingerichtet
nur um welches spiel war das noch mal
nur um ein spiel darauf spielen zu
können
ich weiß jetzt das war ich glaube sogar
2 mw2 ich bin mir nicht sicher ich
glaube es war mw2 wirklich ich habe mir
nur wegen einem spiel nur windows lizenz
gekauft
ordnungsrecht mitkomme aufnehmen am
meisten abgerutscht habe ich bisher bei
fifa ultimate team wenn man die ganze
zeit führt 1 0
und dann kriegt man einer 90 das 1 1 193
das 2 1 und du bist die ganze zeit am
dominieren und der gegner hat durch
diese scheiß diese scheiß momentum
funktionen von fifa einfach das glück
dass seine einzigen beiden chancen rein
gehen
ja ich habe schon den einen oder anderen
controller eine wand geschmissen und
geschrottet ich habe ja gerade eine
tapete ihr seht das ja da hinten ist mit
den steinen aber da aber ihre controller
gegen geworfen und da waren richtig
schwarz kleines löchlein in der wand
welche in das richtig gegen gebrettert
habe also bei fifa kann ich mich
aufregen wie sonst wird mein erstes
spiel ihr wisst ja meine erste mein
erster handheldkonsole dingsbums beide
ja weil die gameboy advance konsole und
mein erstes spiel dafür war super mario
bros
das war noch das ganz alte wo man am
anfang da so drin wenn man die nach
links ein level und nach rechts oder man
noch so wasserfälle und das finde ich
echt unglaublich gern mal wieder spielen
müsste ich mir wieder etwas kaufen oder
es psp fand ich übrigens war die coolste
konsole bisher nochmals ein anderer fügt
aber das nicht gleich im gras zu
bestellen aber das war auf jeden fall
mein erstes spielfeld nummer 15 ist ich
kann nicht ruhig bleiben beim zocken
also egal ob jemand neben mir sitzt oder
ob ich gegen jemand anderen online
spiele oder so oder auch wenn ich
alleine im singleplayer was nicht kalt
verschaffe und das ist mit einer nacht
ist alleine davor dann raste ich total
aus und beleidige einfach alles in
meiner umgebung sagt dann
scheiße hier diese scheiß konsole ja ein
bisschen lauter ich bin so ein bisschen
altmodisch was steuerungselemente angeht
und zwar ihr wisst ja wenn man duckt
sich mit c und ich mache das immer noch
mit alt und alles möglich da noch nie
verändert mit der hand genauso ist es
bei minecraft man kann jetzt mit
steuerungs sprinten
das ist auch schon das ist auch schon
seit längerem so habe ich nutze immer
noch doppelt weh weil ich finde einfach
so never change a running system an mir
läuft's mit doppel b deswegen möchte das
auch noch mit doppel ich habe total das
pech beim konsolen kaufen zwei damals
nintendo 3ds gekauft der hatte nach drei
tagen ein wackelkontakt und abstand
neuen bekommen und ich habe jetzt auch
vor fünf tagen nur view gekauft hab die
ganze einstellung vorgenommen abgestürzt
neugestaltet gespielt ist abgestürzt und
wieder neu gestalteten youtube gehen ist
abgestürzt muss ich auch zurückgeben
wird nintendo geschickt krieg in zehn
tagen wahrscheinlich auch wieder der
neue also ich hab immer total abbrechen
da stehen zehn millionen die umlage und
ich nehmen genau die die in vita pooth
ist ja ich bin einfach keine ahnung
irgendwie soll es nicht sein auch sehr
witzig ich habe mir vor einem jahr
battlefield 3 für playstation 3 gekauft
hab es nie ausgepackt und habs vor einem
monat wieder bei ebay verkauft so als
neueren hab einfach so nur den halben
preis dafür bekommen ist einzig dafür
gekauft haben liegen lassen du hast für
den halben preis wieder verärgert weil
ich einfach nicht spielen wollte nicht
gespielt habe und das war wirklich noch
ein poliert und alles mögliche und aber
ich bin so dumm gewesen damals die
neunzehnte sache ist ich habe erst wie
sieht sich eigentlich mache ich hatte
die ganze zeit im gesamten elefanten so
wenn man das könnte das also ich habe
erst einmal eine lan party ohne ein
kleines schläfchen überstanden sonst was
immer so um 4 uhr den ich mir so eine
müde kurz schlafen halbe stunde wieder
aufwachen gegen halb fünf und weiter
zocken und ja also ich habe erst einmal
eine komplette nacht durchgemacht einer
lan party aber ich glaube ich 14 oder so
und sonst bin ich echt immer eingeplant
weil ich einfach so einen chronischen
schlafen und hab die letzte sache ist
letztes jahr auf der gamescom konnte ich
gar kein spiel an spielen habe ich gar
kein spiel an gespielt das heißt wir
darüber gelaufen durch ganzen hallen
haben dauert zu trinken kann auf das
essen
zurückgefahren zug weil ich keine lust
habe mich drei stunden anzustellen nur
um zehn minuten zocken zu können bei
einem spiel was ihnen monat später
rauskommt das war der fifa damals so da
denkt man einfach nur sowas soll das
verstehen dass so viele leute
das regt mich ein bisschen auf das dann
zum beispiel nicht viele hatten nur
einen stand das wifi fünf stände hat
aber das ganze viel besser gewesen
vielmehr konsole und alles und ja das
war es auf jeden fall mit dem sexvideo
des rat pack nummer 20
und ich würde sagen wenn ihr sowas
eventuell noch von anderen dingen wollte
beispielsweise luca beim autofahren oder
irgendwas anderes dann schreibt sie nun
in die kommentare und last auf jeden
fall ein mag ich da das würde mich auf
jeden fall sehr freuen
und dann würde ich sagen denen wir uns
morgen wieder bei einem coolen video was
ich glaube ich gerade noch gar nicht
geplant habe weil ich muss alles in
urlaub nach plan
auf jeden fall kommt jeden tag in den
nächsten zwei wochen ein video teams